JIM, BACK TO.
>> ALL RIGHT, JOE JOHNS.
WE KNOW EMOTIONS ARE RUNNING
THE HIGH, WE KNOW YOU'RE GOING
TO SEE ON TOP OF IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
JOINING ME NOW IS CNN'S CHIEF
LEGAL ANALYST, JEFFREY TOOBIN.
JEFFREY, GREAT TO HAVE YOU WITH
US.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU WANT THIS DAY WAS COMING,
AND IT CAME.
YOU WERE DEAD ON ABOUT THIS,
JEFFREY.
AND TYPICALLY, WHEN THE SUPREME
COURT REVERSES ITSELF, IT TO
GRANT MORE RIGHT, NOT TO TAKE
THEM AWAY AFTER 50 YEARS.
HOW DO YOU THINK THIS IS GOING
TO GO DOWN IN THE HISTORY OF
THE SUPREME COURT?
>> WELL, THIS IS CERTAINLY A
MAJOR MOMENT IN THE HISTORY OF
THE SUPREME COURT.
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW IT WILL BE
REGARDED IN THE FUTURE.
BUT YOU KNOW, THE REGION THE
RETIRED WAS PREORDAINED IS
BECAUSE THE CONSERVATIVE
MOVEMENT MOBILIZED TO MAKE ITS
POLITICAL INFLUENCE FELT IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
YOU KNOW, DONALD TRUMP SAID IN
THE CAMPAIGN, REPEATEDLY,
INCLUDING IN ONE DEBATE WITH
HILLARY CLINTON, HE SAID, I AM
GOING TO APPOINT JUSTICES WHO
WILL VOTE TO OVERTURN ROE V.
WADE.
HE APPOINTED THEM, THREE
JUSTICES WHO VOTED TO OVERTURN
ROE V. WADE.
AND WHEN YOU COMBINE THAT WITH
CLARENCE THOMAS AND SAMUEL
ALITO, WHO HAD ALREADY
EXPRESSED THEIR DESIRE TO DO SO,
YOU KNOW, THAT DOESN'T MAKE ME
A CLAIRVOYANT, THAT JUST MAKES
ME SOMEONE WHO LISTENS TO WHAT
PEOPLE SAY.
AND THAT JUST, SO YOU KNOW,
THIS DECISION WAS IN NORWAY'S
SURPRISE.
>> AND AS YOU KNOW, JEFFREY, I
MEAN THE REPUTATIONS ARE
FAR-REACHING.
THERE ARE STATES WITH TRIGGER
BANDS GOING INTO PLACE, THERE
ARE STATES WITH VERY OUTDATED
LAWS, AYMAN LAWS THAT DATE BACK
DECADES, MORE THAN A CENTURY, I
GUESS, IN WISCONSIN'S CASE, IT
GOES BACK TO 1849 AND IT'S, UP
IN HERE TO SOME EXTENT WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN IN SOME OF
THESE PLACES.
BUT THE REPERCUSSIONS COULD GO
EVEN FURTHER THAN THAT.
JUSTICE CLARENCE THOMAS IN HIS
KICK CURRYING CONCURRING
OPINION HAD SAID THAT THEY
SHOULD RECONSIDER DUE PROCESS
PRESIDENTS ON OTHER CASES
INCLUDING SAME-SEX MARRIAGE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
I MEAN, HOW FAR REACHING COULD
THIS BE?
>> IT'S ENORMOUS.
AND IT DOESN'T JUST AFFECT THE
RED STATES.
I'M IN, REMEMBER, MANY OF THE
STATES THAT ARE DECLARING
ABORTION ILLEGAL OR ALSO SAYING
THAT ANYONE WHO AIDS OR ABETS
AND ABORTION COULD BE
CRIMINALLY PROSECUTED.
THAT MEANS PEOPLE IN THE STATES
WHO SENT MONEY, WE SENT
MEDICATION ABORTIONS TO PEOPLE
IN RED STATES, AND THEY COULD
BE PROSECUTED.
WHAT ABOUT THE CORPORATIONS WHO
ARE SAYING, WE WILL PAY TO HAVE
OUR EMPLOYEES TRAVEL TO PLACES
WHERE THEY CAN GET AN ABORTION?
IS THAT AIDING AND ABETTING AN
ABORTION?
I MEAN, THE LEGAL, JUST THE
PRACTICAL LEGAL IMPLICATIONS OF
THE DECISION YESTERDAY ARE
ENORMOUS.
AND THAT'S EVEN BEFORE YOU GET
TO THE POINT YOU WERE RAISING
ABOUT CLARENCE THOMAS'S OPINION,
WHICH, I MEAN, HE'S RIGHT IN
THAT THE LOGIC OF THE DOBBS
OPINION, THE ONE FROM YESTERDAY,
CERTAINLY DOES SUGGEST THAT
LAWS, THAT LAWS LIMITING
CONTRACEPTION, LIMITING
CONSENSUAL SEXUAL ACTIVITY,
BANNING SAME SEX MARRIAGE, THAT
LOGIC WOULD SUGGEST THOSE LAWS
COULD STAND.
>> AND I HAVE TO ASK YOU ABOUT
THIS, I DON'T KNOW IF YOU SAW
THIS TWEET FROM SENATOR JOHN
CORNYN OF TEXAS, HE WAS
TWEETING A RESPONSE TO FORMER
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA, OBAMA
WAS CRITICIZING THE OVERTURNING
OF ROE V. WADE, THE OVERTURNING
OF PRESIDENT.
AND I GET SENATOR CORNYN
RE-TWEETED OBAMA AND SAID, NOW
DO PLESSY VERSUS FERGUSON,
BROWN VERSUS BOARD OF EDUCATION,
OBVIOUSLY GOING BACK TO THOSE
MOMENTOUS DECISIONS, WHAT DID
YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> I THINK HE'S BEEN WIDELY
MISUNDERSTOOD, AND HE'S ISSUED
SOME CLARIFYING TWEETS.
I THINK IT'S SOMETIMES A GOOD
IDEA TO EXPRESS YOURSELF AT
GREATER LENGTH THAN 240
CHARACTERS.
WHAT HE WAS SAYING --
>> I SHOULD SAY HE, HE TWEETED
A CLARIFICATION SAYING THAT,
THANK YOU SCOTUS PRESIDENTS ARE
OVERRULED.
>> YEAH, HIS ORIGINAL TWEET,
ALL IT MEANT WAS THAT SOME BAD
SUPREME COURT DECISIONS SHOULD
BE OVER OVERTURNED.
AND HE MEANT THAT RESCUERS,
THIS IS A GOOD THING THAT
POLICY WAS OVERTURNED BY BROWN
V. BOARD OF EDUCATION.
NOW HE MEANS IT'S A GOOD THING
THAT ROE V. WADE WAS OVERTURNED
BY DOBBS.
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE CAN DISAGREE
WITH HIM ABOUT ABORTION BUT HE
WAS NOT SEEN THAT WE SHOULD GO
BACK TO THE DAYS OF SEPARATE
BUT EQUAL.
>> AND I HAVE TO ASK YOU,
JEFFREY, IF, HOW DID WE GET TO
THE TOP DECISION?
I KNOW YOU AND I HAVE TALKED
ABOUT THIS BEFORE.
HAD AMY COHEN BARRETT NOT BEEN
RUSHED ONTO THE SUPREME COURT,
WHICH YOU KNOW FLEW IN THE FACE
OF WHAT MITCH MCCONNELL SAID
WHEN HE BLOCKED A MERRICK
GARLAND BACK WHEN MERRICK
GARLAND WAS BEING PUT FORWARD
BY THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION,
HOW THOSE EVENTS NOT TAKEN
PLACE, WE WOULD NOT HAVE THIS
DUMPS DECISION YESTERDAY.
I MEAN, THAT IS JUST A FAIR
READING OF EVENTS, CORRECT?
OR HELP ME --
>> TOTALLY.
IT'S EVEN BROADER THAN THAT,
YOU KNOW?
THE CREDIT OR RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE DOBBS DECISION,
DEPENDING ON?
HOW YOU VIEW IT, AND GOES TO
MICHOACÁN AL AS MUCH AS IT GOES
TO DONALD TRUMP.
HE IS THE ONE THAT PREVENTED
MERRICK GARLAND FROM REPLACING
ANTONIN SCALIA.
HERE'S THE ONE WHO PUSHED
THROUGH BRETT KAVANAUGH IN
SPITE OF THE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST HIM.
HERE'S THE ONE WHO JUMPED
THROUGH AMY CONEY BARRETT TO
REPLACE RUTH BADER GINSBURG IN
EXTREMELY ABBREVIATED PROCESS.
THOSE ARE THE THREE TRUMP
JUSTICES.
TO, IF NOT ALL THREE OF THEM
WOULDN'T BE ON THE COURT BUT
FOR MITCH MCCONNELL.
HE IS A, HERE IS ONE OF THE
ABSOLUTELY CENTRAL FIGURES IN
THE HISTORY OF THE MODERN
SUPREME COURT.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS
FLASHBACK.
ONE SENATOR SUSAN COLLINS WAS
AGAINST, SAYS SHE WAS AGAINST
ROE V. WADE.
DEFENDED VOTING FOR BOTH NEIL
GORSUCH AND BRETT KAVANAUGH.
PUTTING THEM ON THE SUPREME
COURT.
HERE'S WHAT SHE SAID.
>> NEIL GORSUCH, FOR WHOM YOU
VOTED, DON'T YOU THINK HE IS
PROBABLY GONNA VOTE TO OVERTURN
ROE V. WADE GIVEN THE CHANCE.
>> I ACTUALLY DON'T.
ARE YOU 100% CERTAIN, WITHOUT A
DOUBT, THAT BRETT KAVANAUGH
WILL NOT OVERTURN ROE V. WADE.
>> I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT BRETT
KAVANAUGH WILL OVERTURN --
>> PRESIDENTS ARE OVERTURNED
ALL THE TIME.
>> THEY AREN'T OVERTURNED ALL
THE TIME.
>> I MEAN, JEFFREY, YOU AND I
HAVE TO ALSO TALK ABOUT THIS.
HOW KAVANAUGH, GORSUCH, AMY
CONEY BARRETT.
THEY ALL GAVE ASSURANCES.
I KNOW PEOPLE WANT TO DUNK ON
SUSAN COLLINS, BUT THESE WERE
NOMINEES TO THE SUPREME COURT
GIVING THE COUNTRY ASSURANCES
THAT THEY WERE NOT GOING TO
OVERTURN THIS PRESIDENT.
YEAH, THEY DID ANYWAYS.
HOW DO YOU THINK SUSAN COLLINS
STATEMENTS STANDOUT NOW?
ALSO, WHAT ABOUT THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE PUTTING
THEMSELVES FORWARD FOR A SPOT
ON THE HIGH COURT OF THIS
COUNTRY, WHO ARE ESSENTIALLY
MISLEADING THE COUNTRY ABOUT
WHAT THEIR TRUE INTENTIONS
MIGHT BE, IF ROE V. WADE WERE
TO COME TO THEIR DESK?
>> YOU KNOW, IT IS HARD TO KNOW
WHERE TO START.
[LAUGHS]
>> YEAH.
>> SUSAN COLLINS IS NOMINALLY
AN INDEPENDENT REPUBLICAN, BUT
WHO DOES WHAT MITCH MCCONNELL
WANTS AND REALLY NEEDS.
SHE VOTED AGAINST AMY CONEY
BARRETT BECAUSE MITCH MCCONNELL
DIDN'T NEED HER VOTE.
BUT, HE REALLY NEEDED HER VOTE
ON BRETT KAVANAUGH.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF SUSAN
COLLINS WAS REALLY BELIEVING
BRETT KAVANAUGH OR SHE WAS JUST
GIVING HERSELF A CHANCE TO DO
MITCH MCCONNELL'S BIDDING AS
SHE FREQUENTLY DOES INDICTS OR
STANCES AS FOR THE JUSTICES
THEMSELVES, YOU KNOW, THEY WERE
PLAYING A GAME TO GET ON THE
SUPREME COURT.
ALL THREE OF THEM ARE LAWYERS
SO, IF YOU PARSE THEIR WORDS
CAREFULLY THE WAY LAWYERS KNOW
HOW TO SPEAK, THEY DID NOT
EXPLICITLY PROMISE TO UPHOLD
ROE V. WADE --
>> RIGHT >> THEY LEFT THE
IMPRESSION THAT THEY WOULD
UPHOLD ROE V. WADE.
WHICH WAS ENOUGH FOR SUSAN
COLLINS.
THIS WAS A GAME THAT THEY WERE
PLAYING.
BUT, YOU KNOW THOSE OF US WHO
HAD STUDIED THE RECORDS OF
BRETT KAVANAUGH, OF AMY CONEY
BARRETT OF NEIL GORSUCH, KNEW
THIS DAY WAS COMING.
SUSAN COLLINS HAD TO KNOW IT
TOO BECAUSE ANYONE WITH ANY
SENSE SHE HAS PLENTY OF SENSE,
I DO KNOW THIS WAS COMING.
AND IT DID.
HERE WE ARE THE PRESIDENT ASKED
WITH SOME OF THESE ISSUES
PARTICULAR.
THE IDEA OF SPENDING THE
SUPREME COURT --
HE IS THROWING COLD WATER ON
THAT IDEA.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> YOU KNOW, I GUESS I AM
ENOUGH OF A TRADITIONALIST TO
THINK THAT THAT IS A PRETTY BAD
IDEA.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
THAT THE NUMBER OF SUPREME
COURT JUSTICES IT'S NOT SET IN
THE CONSTITUTION.
IT IS SIMPLY LAY A LOT LIKE ANY
OTHER THAT COULD BE CHANGED.
YOU KNOW, UP UNTIL JUST AFTER
THE CIVIL WAR, THE NUMBER OF
THE JUSTICES DID CHANGE SEVERAL
TIMES BUT, YOU KNOW, IF YOU
START GETTING INTO A SITUATION
WHERE THE PARTY THAT DOESN'T
LIKE SUPREME COURT DECISIONS
STARTS INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
JUSTICES, THAT IS AN ARMS RACE
THAT I THINK COULD NOT REALLY
END WELL FOR THE COURT OR THE
COUNTRY.
FRANKLIN ROOSEVELT DISCOVERED
THAT WHEN HE TRIED TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF JUSTICES AFTER
THE NEW DEAL.
I THINK DEMOCRATS WERE
FRUSTRATED BY THE SUPREME COURT,
THEY NEED TO DO WHAT ROOSEVELT
DID.
WHEN ELECTIONS THAT IS WHERE
THE FUTURE OF ABORTION IS GONNA
BE DECIDED, PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTIONS.
SENATORIAL ELECTIONS NOW, STATE
EL